hey guys this is November the eighth
you're watching games but news my name
is just and I'm here to disappoint you
by not being chastity or Mary here's
what's been going annu video has arrived
from sony calling the ps4 / the world's
most powerful console if that phrase is
ringing a bell for you it's probably
because Microsoft have used very similar
language to describe the upcoming
project Scorpio which is a super-powered
Xbox one the new video shows off a
number of PlayStation games that will
support the proconsul including horizon
zero dawn I'm charted floor and rise of
the Tomb Raider you can watch the video
in 4k although you'll obviously need to
have a 4k display to do so a second
video is released soon after touting the
ps4 pros tech features including dynamic
4k gaming and HDR color the ps4 Pro is
you out on November 10 last weekend at
blizzcon does it explained that they
wouldn't be remastering Warcraft one or
two because they really aren't that fun
anymore during a panel Blizzard
co-founder Frank Pierce explained that
while the publisher does have access to
the original source code and assets it's
still cooked really hard to access that
stuff unlock it and figure out how it
all works he added we had some dedicated
folks that were passionate about the
idea dig up the Warcraft one assets and
code they got it working and they got it
running in a window and I played it
Warcraft orcs and humans was awesome for
its time I promise you in today's world
a by today's standards it's just not
that fun anymore Pierce went on to say
that with their limited resources
Blizzard would rather create more
content for games like overwatch and
World of Warcraft if you are into all
the blizzard stuff though at least
you'll get to tuck into the reworked
content from the original Diablo which
is on its way to Diablo 3 finally update
1.1 has arrived for Skyrim special
edition the patch fixes the game's audio
downgrade which resulted from a
compression issue as well as problems
including the unintentional
disappearance of NPCs alongside that the
update also implements general
performance and optimization
improvements and fixes an issue where
some interface elements would not appear
correctly on certain ps4 and
Fox one displays that is everything I
have for you today do let me know where
you cared about down in that comment box
and I will see you again tomorrow